[Musique]
une exploitation familiale qui est
apparu en
1918 basé principalement sur une
production de miel en sédentaire au
niveau local dans le pays cvrien la
production depuis la création c'est
resté assez stable qui été modifié en
fin de compte c'est la le circuit
commercialisation qui était au départ
tout au détail et qui est passé après 20
en gros et depuis
2021 on revient sur un marché un peu
plus local pour refaire découvrir aux
gens le goût des
miels produit au niveau local alors on a
un miel de colza puisqu'on est dans une
pleain
céréalière après on fait un miel de
printemps et et après au niveau local on
fait un miel de forêt de châigner et on
finit par un miel de tournesol
le terroir suivant où est placée la
ruche on a vraiment un goût différent
par exemple le châigner du pays civrien
n'est pas du tout le même que le châer
de l'Ardèche ou le châtiner du sud de
Laquitaine et chaque année on organise
un le plus gros concours des miels de
France en nouvellequitaine avec le plus
grand nombre de participants et on
découvre vraiment tout un tas de types
le goût sur un même miel et c'est là où
on se rend compte vraiment que le goût
du terroir est très important
pour toute tous les produits en fait et
on a aussi l'effet texture suivant la
texture que je veux donner au miel on a
le goût qui change si je travaille un
miel en crémeux on aura pas le même goût
qu'un miel en liquide je peux me
retrouver donc à l'Intermarché de
savignier on peut venir directement sur
le siège de l'exploitation acheter des
couvrir toute la gamme de miel produit
dans le pays césien et on peut aussi
nous découvrir dans les jardineries
d'ELB à rufec mê ettoire et le mieux
c'est de venir sur l'exploitation pour
pouvoir découvrir toute la gamme et
goûter vraiment échanger avec quand on
vient on peut goûter alors on peut
goûter c'est même recommandé de goûter
un miel avant de l'acheter ça permet de
savoir le vrai goût de nos miel et
vraiment de choisir un miel qui nous
plaît chaque personne a son propre goût
et chaque personne est plus attirée par
un miel en fin de compte on a pas une
personne qui aime pas le miel on a
vraiment des personnes qui préfèrent
certains miel et n'aime pas d'aut miel
d'accord et on peut découvrir
différentes textures et jouer avec les
textures également quel je préfère en
fait alors je préfère le miel de mielade
châigner qui est vraiment une très
petite production qui apparaît à peu
près trois ou quat jours dans l'année
sous certaines conditions de température
et d'humidité et qui donne vraiment un
miel exceptionnel et très très rare
c'est un miel qui reste assez longtemps
liquide et qui est vraiment très fort et
vraiment particularité c'est en
arrièrebouche on a un petit goût de
fruit rouge qui est vraiment super sympa
et surtout n'oubliez pas je suis à deux
pattes chez
[Musique]
vous